el secretario de estado de anthony
blinken en un comunicado oficiales dice
que las farc ya no son una organización
unificada que cometa actos de terrorismo
dice también que sacará las farc de la
lista de organizaciones terroristas le
permitirá al gobierno de eeuu poder
apoyar mejor al gobierno colombiano en
la implementación del acuerdo de paz
firmado en el 2016 y además dice blinken
en este comunicado que le permitirá
trabajar también con los desmovilizados
de las farc con organizaciones de
desmovilizados en colombia sin embargo
blinken aclaró que los guerrilleros que
tengan cargos por narcotráfico o cargos
por crímenes de lesa humanidad van a
seguir con estos cargos acá en eeuu eso
no va a cambiar en absoluto para estas
personas y pues aclaró también el
gobierno de eeuu que las farc ep es
decir las disidencias de las farc a la
segunda marquetalia es designada como y
va a seguir siendo una organización
terrorista para eeuu
concretamente el secretario de estado
dijo que los guerrilleros disidentes que
siguen en esta lista y que por ende
todos sus activos en este país serán
congelados son entre otros luciano marín
arango alias iván márquez también está
el país a romañá y gentiles duarte entre
otros